the white dragon has been released and
is getting geared up and the butterflies
have taken over the police station so
you know this is going to be a
jam-packed episode you know it's podly
the official peacemaker companion
podcast brought to you by hbo max and dc
and you better stick around because of
course we have jennifer holland aka
harcourt coming in to chat with us let's
get into it why is there a bald eagle in
your car that's equal eagerly is your
pet eagle yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
[Applause]
welcome welcome everyone to episode six
of podly the official peacemaker
companion podcast brought to you by hbo
max and dc
and i'm your host fiona nova and i'm
your host cindy waddy way we got a bunch
of twists and turns this episode it
ended in a cliffhanger with leota
discovering that mirn's a butterfly but
plot twist everyone knows that burns a
butterfly yeah so we're gonna be talking
about it chatting about it we got a lot
of things to deep dive into and then we
have an amazing interview with jennifer
holland aka harcourt the love of my life
so
yeah let's get into it
[Music]
so like the episode before you like you
said she finds out mern's butterfly
because she put on the x-ray helmet it's
this big moment then harcourt pulls up
at the start of this episode and
basically reveals that almost everyone
except for vigilante and peacemaker
knows i probably eagerly knows if he was
able to speak
yeah judo master said you know you don't
know uh you know what they're up to
and and it seems like yeah
we didn't know obviously
mirn being a butterfly at that time in
the past episode when we discovered it
it was like oh my gosh yeah but i really
do love the fact that everyone just knew
yeah
everyone was not surprised
and uh i feel like i guess it makes
sense on how they're getting that
information is because there's like an
insider a butterfly is playing both
sides yeah so it's it's pretty
interesting i think it makes it gives
actually the butterflies more character
in my opinion so yeah i know i mean this
was this was a lot of fun to like that
beginning scene
the fun continues when we go to the show
and the show and tell which i was like
where did this come from i know it's
such a fun aside where you get to see
just this kind of lighter side
especially since it seems like things
are about to get more intense so we get
a little more fun before things get uh
super serious and i feel like it will
always be fun but yeah you're right it's
going it's gonna kind of take some turns
maybe some emotional turns and i think
like the show-and-tell part whether it
was it advances the plot or not it is
just a great aside to like and i love
the interaction with a kid
and like
obviously peacemaker who is not good at
any kind of social cues and is probably
not the person who should be talking to
children oh yeah like i don't think he's
the right person to be doing that you
know
wonder woman was i f'ing me yeah he was
like hey he was like i said effing urkel
have you met wonder woman i've never met
her but she did spend an entire party if
and me from across the room sick dude
dude i said effin any more questions
so then we have this issue where um
peacemaker's dad is
out of jail yeah so yeah that was a
whole thing that was so
tough because i'm like yeah okay yeah i
got the wrong person but he's bad let it
happen stop trying to be a super combat
yeah so they free this super-powered
white supremacist because they think
that's what's best uh and they're
they're trying to take in peacemaker
they're on to it and we're also having
this
kind of conversation now that uh
peacemaker is having with goff uh right
yeah goth starts tapping on the jar um
and i that's an also a great interaction
between vigilante and peacemaker they're
always having the best combos of how do
we communicate yeah also vigilante
completely missing the point of asking
yes or no questions okay goth
one tap is yes
two taps is no do you understand
okay golf
is that a peace sign
oh goth what's your favorite color dude
it's it's yes or no questions i just
said it right okay yeah uh goff is your
favorite color teal bro what the [ __ ]
it was it was just so
perfectly
frustrating in that friendly frustrating
way where it's like no we're focusing on
other things right now yeah and i mean
okay so
from there we get the trailers
surrounded
uh because they're trying to take down
peacemaker yeah uh the police are yeah
we have this fateful moment where goff
gets out because it breaks while they're
running out and takes over another
person and it's not just like any person
of like like a really big detective yeah
so
she does have power which we did really
we kind of learned that the butterflies
are taking positions of power yeah it
seems so
this is not just a person that they're
taking over it's someone who has access
to the entire police
yeah and higher-ups and stuff but you
know the peacemaker is eventually able
to get out with uh this cop who was
trying to save him before with the
fingerprints and
she went above his head and now he's
cleaning up after her who is now a
butterfly so it's a real mess and so
from there we jump into like this insane
swarm of butterflies that are now about
to essentially take over
the police department
they are going to take it's a whole
monster you got the you got the
butterflies taking over but then you
also have the white dragon gearing up
gearing up and getting ready yeah yeah
getting all these like white
supremacists to like
essentially it seems like they're going
for peacemakers
they're going to take them down i'm
going to take them down so it's it's a
whole mess
and the only thing that can calm us down
after seeing all of that is seeing that
uh
peacemaker actually is making some
progress with harcourt that scene was
really interesting because uh not only
did we get that kind of soft side of
hardcore but we also got
this really like i think poignant
message from um peacemaker essentially
saying i appreciate this gesture of
putting the the dove right yeah
but it's not the dove i'm worried about
it's like i don't want to kill anyone
anymore like what am i doing i felt like
that was very not only is it just a
heart-to-heart with harcourt but um it's
also just opening up peacemaker to us
seeing that you know he is really trying
to do good but he's maybe just a little
lost and possibly a little dumb yeah not
not possibly new but yeah yeah you know
just uh and then he hops on that piano
and starts tickling the ivories yeah and
that's when we kind of get a glimpse of
like the backstory we're really getting
to like the nooks and crannies of it
and then we have that that bombshell of
a press conference
where the diary has finally been found
which you know that was the moment
because now all of this is yet again
falling on pieces now the relationship
between leota and peacemaker are like
it's on the edge yeah remember she did
that at a time where they were actually
connecting in a big way yeah and now
it's blowing up in her face well i think
she knew what she was doing wasn't super
right but
i think like she's always she kind of
forgot about it and then it got brought
back up and it's like oh no like i we
did all of this together i re i wish i
didn't do this like i know there's going
to be a
ton of regret yeah yeah i mean
that's a recap
and there was a lot of things to talk
about in episode six but we are very
lucky to have jennifer holland here yeah
who plays the love of your life the love
of my life let's kick it over there and
see see what's up
[Music]
we are joined for episode six by the
beautiful and amazing jennifer holland
who has an amazing i love the shirt i am
i i immediately when i saw you i clocked
the shirt and i was like butterflies
[Laughter]
yeah yes
i'm like
of course
how could i not yeah
no it looks so great so listen we've got
a bunch of questions for you but let's
start it off this episode episode six it
just continues to reveal kind of the
softer side of your character harcourt
do you like playing a no-nonsense badass
or do you like digging into that tender
stuff you know the juicy things
i think that you kind of dig into both
of those things you know
i think
i'll
the thing about harcourt is that i just
love her i love every aspect of of who
she is and she's a really complex
complicated um flawed
individual i think she's awesome and i
just feel so grateful
for james to write this really
wonderfully complex character that i get
to portray yeah i know and you
definitely see elements in that when you
know you see the group chat come into
play and you're like oh yeah no they're
it's all uh coming together it seems
like uh we're getting into that uh soft
exterior hopefully and on the like
badass side it looks like we got a you
know big action set piece on the way and
uh how do you like approach the physical
action in the show for me i i grew up as
a competitive gymnast and having the
opportunity
to
use my um athletic abilities in this in
this role was kind of just a dream come
true i i've never gotten to do
action like this before i've gotten to
do little pieces and things but this
stuff is just so juicy and amazing and
we had the most incredible
um fight choreographers
and stunt team
and
they
choreographed in my opinion some of the
most amazing fight sequences throughout
this series i would have not looked cool
at all if it weren't for julia who's my
my stunt double she taught me everything
she spent so much time with me and i had
a great time with her she's really
really awesome
seems like so much fun just to like
roll around jump around like but then i
realized oh no that's probably a really
hard yeah and i probably would break an
ankle
yeah but listen i i think this is
something that i've always wanted to ask
because you play it so straight in the
show like you are you have to keep your
composure you have to like you are the
person who doesn't laugh but you are
playing with
a bunch of goofs
and
i just want to know is how hard was that
to just
be your character when there's like a
dick joke happening right next to you or
like how how were you able to do that i
don't want to discount anyone's you know
role on on a project or anything like
that but to some degree it's a little
bit it's a little bit easier when you
know you don't have to be funny like my
character is
the straight man in a lot of ways and
maybe there's some some comedy that
comes from the situations or something
like that with her but for the most part
she's just authentically who she is so
that's how i was able to approach
everything that i was doing but
i won't lie there's they they broke they
broke me sometimes you know they it's
it's just that the the the non-stop
improv that comes out of john cena is
mind-blowing so you just never know what
you're gonna get and it's great i know
especially after hearing like the
celebrity names were improvised in the
earlier episode uh so he was just
he's running
just i mean it was non-stop
i
just applaud him because i don't even
know where those names
came from in his brain i can't remember
my own name most of the time
well you know speaking of peacemaker it
seems like harcourt's starting to you
know softening on peacemaker and there's
uh you know uh
something growing there is it you know
as that was going on is he grown on
hardcore i think he's always been into
harcourt
peacemaker has has really been into
hardcore throughout the whole
series i think the beauty of the scene
that james wrote in episode six
she goes and she
spends her time engraving a dub of peace
on a weapon for him and that's a huge
gesture for harcourt i think she's
already been on this this path of
accepting
that
she isn't a lone wolf and she finally
found to some degree a family you know
and she accepted that she's not alone
she has
a team and and maybe these possibly
these people are her friends
yeah it's been great i mean i know i
remember that moment when she like when
harcourt grabbed her phone and like took
that picture and seeing that moment kind
of it just made me warm for her
in a way that i can't really explain but
i really love that moment ah that's
really good well like i wanna know
because you have there's a lot of
relationships in this show and i thought
it'd be interesting to see like not tear
them up but like see like what
okay so let's say there's a burning
house
okay let's say there's a burning house
and you've got the gang in there and
harcourt can save them one at a time who
who is hardcore saving first and second
third i wanna know i think i think it's
interesting i want to know so who who do
we think harcourt's saving like okay so
i think that
our court would save adebayo first
i think harcourt believes that adebayo
cannot take care of herself so she would
be afraid that she would need to save on
a bio first so that's that that's that
first one i think secondly she would
definitely save um john economos
because again low-hanging fruit i mean
she and she's worked with john for a
very long time but i think that i think
she'd probably be most concerned about
adebayo and and economos and i think
beyond that
uh you know if it seemed like eagley
wasn't able to to get out of there i
think she'd probably
i think she would begrudgingly save the
bird and then it just goes down from
there it's probably yeah you know then
who cares
yeah that was a great answer yeah i just
wanted to know yeah
peacemaker visits a class show and tell
with mixed results uh so what would you
bring to a show and tell today yeah
i would how about this i would bring
that white dragon costume just so we
could have a conversation about it
because what the heck guys like why are
we talking about
i mean
what the heck is going on
you know
this is so weird we've got a racist
superhero on our show what is happening
you're right and like white dragon was
in the comics which was even wild
because white dragon
there was a point where i was watching
and i was like oh yeah this has to be a
pull cause james have been doing some
deep cut like at this point we've heard
matter eater lad which comes up in every
weird superhero
ranking like we've got so i was like and
sure enough there was a hero and funny
enough he was a member of the suicide
squad at some point so yeah racist uh
anti-hero i'm just gonna say villain
yeah i'm just going yeah super villain
super villain yeah super villain yeah
uh worst nightmare but yeah the suit i
look it's clean it's clean it's clean
it's white
yeah it screams that
we know
you know that's also the person behind
the helmets too which i'm like all right
you don't need you have too much power
sir yeah you go back to jail yeah
yeah well listen we have we have our
favorite segment of this show which we
call eagley mail
[Music]
essentially we take a question from the
community and we ask our guests uh we
asked our guests this question so we
have one
from uh from the dc community which who
asks was eagley a real eagle was eagerly
a real eagle on set
uh no there was no real evil on set no
um i think that
james is smart enough to not work with a
real animal like that
um
it's hard enough to film a movie or a tv
show so no i think that it also doesn't
get you a whole lot i mean i i don't
know uh
other than a headache so i think at one
point they had brought an eagle in for
like motion reference or whatever but it
was always like a
a little stick with a dot on it but it
was it was always a fake eagle
surprise okay follow-up question
would you be willing to work with the
real
um sure
i mean why not
i would i love birds i think birds are
really cool especially if it was a
trained one
i think it would be
a unique challenge
i'm not like a falconer or anything like
that
sounds fun how about you would you like
to work with a a real eagle oh
definitely i just want to want to see
those talons up close because i feel
like you know next to owls evil
eagles are the most evil looking birds
like they always look so angry yeah yeah
i'm gonna have to say no
i'm good
that thing will eat me oh you know i
might peck at you we'll peck at me but
yeah no okay that's great no i mean it
makes total sense that they you know
mocapped it's vfx yeah we can we can do
anything in vfx now we can do it we are
i think we are
untethered now um
that is true yeah well listen i mean
that was our last question for you and
jennifer uh thank you so much for
joining us and chatting with us we had
an amazing time of course uh taking some
time out of your day to hang out with us
it means a lot awesome thank you guys
all right well
that was an amazing interview but you
know what time it is it's time for this
week's peace prize
[Music]
so peacemaker can handle himself in most
situations except when kids are just
owning him yeah continuously
and so the kid with the sad eyes that's
what he said i don't think he had side
eyes but that's what he said
picks a real like does like a deep cut
of lore here that's from batman volume
one issue 133 uh so a tv show in in 2022
out here given a kite man reference hell
yeah
so i think this scene specifically
should definitely get the award of deep
cut 100 [ __ ] that is the i couldn't
think of a more deserving deep cut award
questions
uh yeah kid with the sad eyes
you said the blackheart ruby weighed 30
pounds yes
and kiteman was riding a kite
that's right wouldn't he have crashed
anyway due to gravity
no
look that's another time to talk about
that dc universe infinite you know go
ahead you can you can plug that in and
you can find out about
kite man yourself see see i look i like
that the show is helping us help you get
more you know nerd stuff for your crew
you know well you thanks everyone for
watching uh we gotta get up out of here
you know it's about that time it is
about that time uh but thank you for
watching and listening to
podly the official peacemaker companion
podcast from hbo max and dc and make
sure you're going ahead to subscribe to
us on facebook instagram and on twitter
and giving us your favorite moments from
the show and if you want to rock some
sweet sweet peacemaker merch check out
the shop at
shop.dcomics.com and you can see all the
latest drops and just like i was saying
earlier make sure you sign up for dc
universe infinite that's the one way you
can get be caught up on all the things
referenced on the show and then when
you're all addicted to comics you could
just keep watching them because they
have a subscription service that keeps
you tapped in to the culture
nerd culture that is yeah
all right yeah yeah so uh yeah don't
forget to uh you know follow us like i
said and of course stream peacemaker and
podly on hbo max and uh get ready uh for
the next episode we're getting towards
the end of this and it's only gonna get
better so we'll catch you next time
keep the peace keep in peace
you